therefore verse darker that means the
preamplifier in German Dvorkin stalker
forever starter yeah devolver stalker
yet means yeah yeah the preamplifier
yeah yeah yeah you heard me
they go about to chain two chains on the
over-the-top side and right now we're
going to check out most expensive this
[ __ ] definitely crazy
yo yo yo we back play a partner chicken
in 2 Chainz and today almost expensive
as [ __ ] try to check out the most
expensive speakers come some guy in jail
it's a cool place what you guys set up
right here what's going on
omnidirectional stereo system for you to
check out listen II meaning surround
sound 360° all the way around this
videos on a syllable just the - I'm into
music this is what I don't live yet this
is the MBL reference stereo system from
Berlin Germany these are my favorite
coat did you know that there's a really
black and gold but I can go one thing
looks like
passatti glasses yeah it's got the high
performance it's got to be in a
beautiful package this is die cast
aluminum that's all one piece I can't
believe it look this is the tweeter see
has little segments they all work the
same just different material and shape
for the frequency so it fills the room
in a very natural way lot of sound
pressure and only way to get this is to
get a handmade from Berlin absolutely
well Berlin that's where the idea came
from German engineers do you make
anything customized for like cloves or
venues or anything they're just like a
home our technology is based for the
home but it could certainly be applied
to a larger skill it's a stack that's
three pieces you can actually make
amazing stuff we can put themselves it's
so impressed you grow them around you if
you want them around the couch oh man
that is so dope this is unique amplifier
CD players a lot of people make those
right this setup right here is unique to
its kind of loudspeaker absolutely seem
to be very lords amplified yeah it's big
it weighs 260 pounds are you serious bro
try go ahead I know you're strong guy
give it a lift that's its
it's solid lasers but no one could ever
really take it from here you can you
know I'm worried about yeah it's on four
big feet so you can bolt it to the floor
which we've done for some people in
their yachts or jets
you definitely however have a yacht or a
jet or lyac for that so it won't go
swimming on its own this calls like more
than you'd imagine as you're seeing it
it's two hundred sixty thousand dollars
it's 260 yeah banks like we would say
bang it's 260 bands plus the wires you
can get the wires any way you want it's
not Wireless for 200 spend two hundred
thousand wires you know it's the old
silver you know it's like your your
jewelry accessories I'm about to hear
some oh no [ __ ] best a from you let's
give it a listen let's take a look
[Music]
I appreciate the opportunity but let me
come in and check out this heavy-ass
remote control yeah but I want to hear a
little touching
[Music]
all right thank you okay okay okay you
got me I'm so so put me on backorder man
I got a vision I got some places I want
to put it I can start off with the
$70,000 speaker exactly and move up to
the 260,000 absolutely which is probably
what I want to do all right put the ore
in thanks a lot man thank you 300k
really worth okay
they waste so much you can't even still
a mile someone's home I mean that's the
bargain give me some feedback what you
think leave a comment subscribe to the
GQ channel for more most expensive [ __ ]
[Music]